okay next game
oh yeah of course i wanted to try some
other openings so
let's play a banker for for a change i
didn't play this at
all in the videos and i have
no no
deep knowledge so it's a bit risky
yeah the immediate rook you won yeah i
looked at this
i don't know 15 years ago for white but
server
announcement oops i need to switch this
off
now i completely forgot how this is
played
no idea
queen b6 queen a5
i know i think i think this one this one
actually
but i really forgot
because he didn't play h3 i can i can go
for this
okay maybe this one
yeah does he
threaten something some discoveries with
the knight i don't think so
i can still play this here
i wonder about queen a6 here maybe to
prepare
the knight coming to d3 later
not sure but
it looks interesting
i think maybe maybe this makes sense and
come
in combination with the night placements
when night where knight should come to
d3 later
it doesn't um really have any great move
to not
exchange the queen queen d1 looks
strange and
um what else can he do
can maybe switch around move some
something
h3 first or something like this
okay took
okay but this but this would allow me to
capture a2
right and f2 is hanging so
i think i should just take him
how does he cover f2 now
it's not just the pawn also
the knight immediately afterwards
oh i like the banker this went well
okay i think he needs to block the
second rank somehow
knight to 92 or something
rook c2 then maybe but then he's got
rook c1
which which doesn't look great but
should should be should be working
okay
so what now
yeah i could try of course to to get a
knight to d3
anyway maybe to before then
i'm not sure
maybe this knight to e5 on h3
on h3
i'll play this one covering e7 maybe i
have
f5 to undermine the d5
pawn okay
i'll go rook c2 now he needs to
play rook c1 anyway
could go just to k8 i just played
yeah it's still fairly solid for white i
think
especially if you can get the rooks off
okay okay let's let's go f5 now
try to get some play against this pawn
chain
so
yeah of course f5 is also weak but
it's not um not easy to attack i think
at least without giving me some some
other options
not c4 e3 he could try but i'm still on
the second
rank so knight b6 is just a threat
he's getting very low on time now
let's see what he comes up with h3
yeah let's just attack d5 i
don't think he can cover it
yeah the d5 pawn is just gone
i'll take now does he have i know i've
also i have also uh knight e3
okay now this one okay let's uh
still let's check knight c3 rook c1 yeah
yeah it's a winning rook and game
yeah maybe this is a simple solution
um
time warning
check
yeah black spawns are very
very compact here
and b3 is just falling besides the time
factor
white forfeits on time yeah last on time
yeah this was very nice after he he gave
me the a2 pawn
and this f5 idea i think was pretty
effective
i'm not sure maybe he needs to um
to play something else here of course
this wasn't the best because it just
loses d5 but
not sure of course you don't want to
play
f3 it looks very ugly second rank
i also have knight e3 c2 then yeah
yeah it's a bad position what can you do
you simply
cannot allow me to to take on a2